♪ ♪ ♪
- Le Festival du Nouveau Cinéma
célèbre cette année
un demi-siècle d'existence.
Et c'est la magie du cinéma,
il n'a pas pris une ride.
- Cette année encore, le FNC
offre l'occasion de voir
des film internationaux primés
comme "Parallel Mothers"
de Pedro Almodovar qui valu
à Penelope Cruiz le Prix
de la meilleure interprétation
féminine à la Mostra
de Venise...
... ou encore "Un Héro"
du réalisateur iranien
Asghar Farhadi qui a remporté
le Grand Prix du dernier
Festival de Cannes.
Le festival accueille de
la belle visite : Jane Campion
première femme récipiendaire
de la palme d'or pour
la "Leçon de Piano", est en
ville pour présenter son nouveau
film "Le pouvoir du chien".
C'est le très actuel et très
pertinent "Bootlegger"
de Caroline Monet qui a lancé
les Festivités.
CAROLINE MONNET,
Réalisatrice et artiste visuelle
- C'est le festival
incontournable à Montréal, mais
c'est aussi un festival qui m'a
supporté dès mes débuts
de mes courts-métrages.
- La prohibition, c'est
une vieille loi paternaliste.
- Le premier long-métrage
de Caroline Monnet se déroule
sur une réserve autochtone où
est organisé un référendum
sur la vente libre d'alcool.
PASCALE BUSSIÈRE, comédienne
- Ça pourrait pas mieux tomber
je dirais, on est dans
un contexte favorable pour que
ces préoccupations-là émergent.
Il était temps, dirons-nous.
- Les cinéphiles pourront aussi
découvrir "les Oiseaux Ivres",
le film qui représentera
le Canada dans la course
aux Oscars.
L'équipe du film se réjouit que
la première québécoise
ait lieu au FNC.
- La sélection est toujours très
pointue.
- Puis c'est vraiment
une école de cinéma en soi.
- Watch out pour l'indien.
- Fidèle à sa tradition,
le festival propose des films
audacieux formellement et
dans les thèmes qu'ils abordent,
comme la contemplation
du mystère.
EMMANUEL SCHWARTZ, comédien
- Pour moi, c'est aussi beaucoup
sur la mue spirituelle
du personnage, c'est-à-dire
quelqu'un qui est attéré,
déprimé et un peu sans reprères
et puis trouve espoir
dans un endroit inusité
puis ça lui permet de grandir.
Le FNC est aussi
un laboratoire et un lieu
de rencontre important
pour l'industrie
cinématographique d'ici.
ALBERIC AURTENÈCHE, scénariste
et réalisateur
- C'est aussi le festival
dans lequel j'ai vu certains
films qui ont influencé
la création de
"la Contemplation
du Mystère."
- Après une année de pause,
le festival est de retour
en salle et sans limite
de spectateurs.
NICOLAS GIRARD DELTRUC, Dir.,
Festival du Nouveau Cinéma
- Je pense qu'il y avait
une grosse revanche pour
l'équipe de cette année
d'y parvenir.
- Le 50e anniversaire du FNC
se poursuit jusqu'au 17 octobre.
Bon cinéma.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪